um oh my god i mean
are you confused or just that ambitious
both yeah okay well go like dive into
both of those then
i always i say cursed with ambition
because like
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the pretty intense podcast i
said the name of the podcast because i
think it's appropriate because today i
spoke with nate
boyer who is a former green beret
a former nfl long snapper and
was also a good friend in giving colin
kaepernick some advice to take a knee
instead of sitting on the bench which
we all know made a lot of news
i didn't even i didn't even scratch the
surface on all the things that he's done
he
is always looking for the next thing
that he's drawn to he
goes all over the place he's been all
over the world
he's been sneaky he's snuck into
countries to go
help them out when he wasn't even
allowed in i mean like he
he's just a different thinker and um
and he's just done a lot of really
amazing things so it was fun to talk to
him about what motivates him
i actually asked him whether or not he
was confused or really inspired
because he's done so many fantastic
things um
but he brings like a fresh a fresh
attitude towards
not being afraid to change your mind and
do something new
so i hope you're inspired because i sure
was enjoy
i wrote this down because i don't want
to get it wrong and i want to
make sure everyone understands to some
degree
your ambition level so you solo
backpacked in europe and central america
fishermen in san diego you're a big
brother and mentor for autistic kids you
volunteered at a refugee camp in darfur
climbed mount kilimanjaro um you're an
actor
you took firefighting classes and you
played college and nfl football
did i leave anything really important
out of that or military
oh yeah that's right that's right that's
a whole bullet point later the entire
military
situation that lasted for nine years
yeah nine years so um yeah other than
that nine year thing
um oh my god i mean
are you confused or just that ambitious
both yeah okay well go like dive into
both of those then
i always i i say cursed with ambition
because like
i mean i love it i love chasing all
those things and and
you know it's never about achieving
really i mean yes you want to achieve
but
like it's the hustle and like learning a
new skill for me
and kind of uncovering whatever the
mystery is of this thing that i don't
know how to do and now i want to learn
it
i'm like obsessed with that and uh
yeah and then once i sort of accomplish
it i feel like all right let's
move on to something else let's try
something else um but all those things
have been motivated by
sort of the thing i did before it kind
of like led into the next
deal if that makes sense do you have a
like i mean for me
i know my life changes every couple of
years in ways i'll never expect and like
it just kind of seems to go like that do
you have
do you feel like you find sort of that
like oh yeah a couple years have gone by
i'm bored or is it
because you said it didn't have to do
with like succeeding at that one thing
it's more about
learning about it yeah i mean i
definitely want to succeed
but like the part i enjoy is like when
it's a new thing
and i'm trying to like crack the code on
it and i get excited when it's just like
this unknown
situation especially something that's
challenging like i'm sure i mean
everything i've done other millions of
people have done it's just i hadn't done
that thing yet and i haven't done this
thing yet and then once i got to get
into it
i get like that the sensations in my
body that you know
you're just like i don't know what that
is the endorphins or whatever when it's
like something that's like
um really motivating to you and
you know like it's gonna be tough but
like you can see
somehow that light at the end of the
tunnel and maybe if i can make this
thing happen you know i'll wow myself i
don't know
i think like that too like i'm like oh
this workout's gonna be so hard but
that's kind of what i'm thinking i'm not
like
thinking i'm gonna go to darfur i'm
going to hike my kilimanjaro
i'm going to go to the military i know i
decided i want to go to the nfl
like i might not think on the scale that
you're thinking as far as like
achieving a new um learning a new talent
what has been what has been the hardest
one
oh i mean i think odds-wise
probably the nfl to be honest just
because i'm not a great athlete
you know i'm really not you offended so
many people
right there by saying that i made it to
the nfl but i'm just not really there i
got it i got cut in like five minutes so
it's like it's all right
no but like you know what you've played
college for five years so obviously
you're talented yeah uh i think
okay yes yes somewhat uh
athletically inclined i think but i just
work
really hard and i like had to find a
niche because i wasn't
i wasn't very if i wasn't fast enough to
play safety like i wanted to right
so i had to discover long snapping which
is a thankless job
and it was something that i could
compare to
skills i learned in the military and if
i just stuck with it committed
and understood that i'm probably gonna
suck at this thing for a few months
eventually um what's gonna go one by the
one way or the other i'm either gonna
figure it out or i'm just
not and i'll just move on and do
something else but i think
most people just quit you know i mean
you think of like
we're talking about workouts like p90x i
mean of all the p90xs that were sold i
bet
not that many percentage-wise actually
were completed did it
yeah totally i have a workout program in
my book it's like the name of the show
pretty intense comes from the name of my
book because just
really honestly a very accurate
descriptor of me um but
you know the people that did the program
like
you know the people that there was only
i did focus group and there was 700
people that signed
up to do the focus group test and i mean
probably
40 finished you know what i mean you're
like gosh so here's what i'm
i feel like this is what i'm hearing
quick and sudden at the beginning here
is that there's no way you do all these
things
without having a
big disconnection and a lack of fear for
failure
i think i do still fear it though
because i just said like if it if it
doesn't work out it doesn't work out but
that's sort of what motivates me like i
kind of
like i know if i'm a little bit nervous
about something or afraid of something
that's the right thing for me like i
sort of i'm attracted to that you know
what i mean
and i think most people uh would run
away from that so like it's not that i
don't recognize it
um or feel it it's just that for
whatever reason
i'm like okay with it you know so you
feel that fear and excitement equally
or you feel them both right yeah you're
excited about it but you're like
i'm scared of this yeah exactly scared
shitless but hey let's go
let's go climb that mountain you got to
feel that racing like you have to have
some fear i just drive slower
i mean there's no way you're like right
you have to have some like never like
and maybe it's not the speed you're
racing at or like a fear of a wreck or
whatever but it's like
i mean it was actually what i feel
making a mistake or whatever people ask
me what i feared i said i fear failing
you're right right exactly um so
uh what was fear quit i fear quitting
you know and
yeah i fear the regret of like you know
chickening out yeah on something that i
know i want to do deep down
yeah so that mo that that's that's a
strong
not yet obviously man this went on i've
left out a nine year element
i've failed a lot of things but i
haven't but i haven't i've yet to
you know maybe relationship wise a
little bit but we don't need to get into
that well maybe you shouldn't be so busy
exactly but uh besides that
what um what uh what if those things
have been the most
fulfilling i would say
well you know what i mean i think that
the easy answer
would be the military stuff because
i mean it was nine years of my life i
learned so much from that from the
you know the men and women i fought
alongside and like
experiences i feel like there's some
magic in the military as far as like
the brotherhood the camaraderie the the
selflessness
the there's something in it because
there's i don't feel like there's very
many people that come away from an
experience in the military and have bad
things to say about it so maybe
tell me about that yeah i think i think
uh
i mean part of it is that those those
intense
uh circumstances you know what i mean
like that elevates
uh connection i think because i mean you
go off to basic training or whatever
unit you're in
and we're the most diverse
microcosm in america you know like large
one anyway
i mean there's there's over a million
people at a given time that wear
camouflage
and different religions skin colors
beliefs
from every state and other countries
yeah and we don't all like each other we
don't all get along
but like we figured out and we sort of
rise above all the [ __ ]
and are willing to do whatever it takes
to protect the man next to us and
because we know they would do the same
for us and when you when your life's on
the line you literally feel that
it just i mean it's a tough question i i
don't know what it is exactly
it's it's it's the training you go
through um i mean when you when you
have that intense uh those intense
training moments where you know you you
don't have a lot of food
um you've been up for days that wouldn't
work it sucks
you know it's like you're cold wet tired
miserable all that stuff
um you just
you have to lean on the people around
you you have to have that community you
know
so it's a vulnerability perhaps yeah
there is a vulnerability for sure
because
you're physically exhausted you're
mentally exhausted your life is
on the line you're asking for help right
because you can't do it by yourself so
um you know there's there's an amazing
that connection that happens when we say
we need help
right uh because you're you're put
you're
you're trusting someone else which
creates a bond yeah
then and then it's and it's like counter
to what society tells us is tough and
strong
you know asking for asking for help but
the reality is it's stronger you know
admitting like i'm
i need help in this moment i'm not 100
okay like
things are tough right now i could use a
hand
but like we've been conditioned our
whole lives to think that that's
like no a strong person just like
doesn't ask for help doesn't it can do
everything i just tough it out
it's completely wrong do you think that
it's something that has
if you haven't necessarily thought about
it sort of in an
obvious cognitive way that is the
magic of it almost do you feel like the
experience of that
has seeped into other things that you've
done as far as like
the camaraderie and the the bonds and
the friendship and
asking for help and trusting other
people did you see that
um infiltrate other other parts of your
life
after yeah i mean unknowingly you know
when i got out of
when i came off of active duty and went
to college i went to university of texas
i was 29 years old so i was like
you know 10 years older than the other
freshmen and
i had was there was fear in that moment
of like i'm not going to fit in no one's
going to understand me at all
it's going to be like adam sandler and
old school and uh billy madison yeah
where he shows up to high school with
the t-rex he's got a jean jacket on his
collar popped
and everybody's looking at him like
who's he who's the old guy
yeah i piss my pants and all that stuff
if pee in your pants is cool then
consider me miles davis
exactly but yeah i mean i i had that
and unknowingly i mean i had this also
this like dream of goal of like i want
to play football i've never played
before
and i regret it um and so i'm gonna go
walk on and make the team it's gonna
make it happen
and you know unknowingly
that helped me transition to that next
stage in life because of that locker
room and the team and like
as you talk about those similarities um
and i
if i just apply applied that same work
ethic
and tried to be a leader in that same
way for these young guys because i mean
these
you know incredible athletes um but a
lot of them they're very young they
don't have a lot of life experience yeah
and uh and it's you know you're going
out there you're playing in front of a
hundred thousand yeah
like a right away and you gotta go to
you know make grades in class
and and you got pre you know 40 60 hours
a week of
practice films and you're looking at
them going yeah but you're like
you're not you know you don't have a gun
pointed at you yeah exactly it's gonna
be okay it's not that bad
that's exactly it though it was like
trying to you know help relate
other experiences to them um
you know but also like push that
strength and vulnerability you know to
them and like
help them understand that if you need
help on something
or if you're not out there playing for
the person next to you just like we did
in the military you know fighting for
the man on our left and right
uh the team's not gonna win like we're
not gonna be successful in that first
year i was on the team
i didn't play that first year i was
redshirting but we were we did not
we weren't good we lost a lot of games
you know and i didn't really say a lot
that year i'm not
saying we got better because i stepped
up but i just felt like if i'm not
playing it's hard for me to even though
with my background to be that leader in
the locker room i feel like i need to be
on the field so then
once i got on the field and was playing
yeah i was like okay now i can speak
credibility yeah exactly but uh but you
know
i think with all that being said
the the thing in my life that shifted
the most that kind of
affected me more than anything was
actually it was only
six weeks or so but that that time in
the darfur
doing the relief work because it was
what led me to the military
and i was completely lost so how old
were you when you went to darfur i was
23. okay so i got out of uh
i i got to graduate high school thought
i wanted to be a firefighter went to
firefighter school down san diego
um i it wasn't that i didn't want to be
a firefighter i just wasn't really
ready to grow up i think um it was a
very like you know you got to take that
seriously boys just take a lot longer
than girls it's okay that's true
that's very true i'm still working on it
um
and then i started working on a fishing
boat down there just to make money and i
loved it it was pretty good money for an
18 year old kid so i did that for like a
year and then i moved up here and you
know
odd jobs and then 9 11 happened and i
started thinking about the military but
still didn't join right away because i
just wasn't sure what i would do
and i just didn't know if i could handle
it i didn't believe myself at that time
i was a very different person
oh really yeah just hard on myself and
you know just i don't know insecure
whatever okay it was just like that was
my hardest face
some kids it's younger like you said
boys mature slow
for me like my early 20s were not a good
there was a dark time
and uh and i i read about what was going
on in the darfur the genocide
uh in a time magazine article and i just
i didn't
wasn't leaving anything important back
here so i decided to just go over there
and
figure it out and i got there talked my
way onto a un flight got out to the
refugee camps and volunteered for
like six weeks you snuck out there is
that right like
tell the story about that because people
are trying to probably get out and
you're trying to get in
well i wanted to go with like uh doctors
without borders or one of those
organizations right
and i called them all but because i
didn't have a college degree
and it was like six months of red tape
and i don't know some kind of training
stuff they wouldn't let me go but i was
like
you were more ready i was ready and i
was like i'm reading
about how you're understaffed at the
camps like you need people and i'm like
i'll do
anything i mean it's like people having
to pay for dogs at the at the shelter or
adopting a child it's like these these
animals and
children need homes why are you making
it hard right right right yeah
that's what i thought that's what it
felt like for sure but uh
just showing up there helps though i
mean there was a few people that were
like
i mean people thought i was in the cia i
got like interrogated all this crazy
stuff and i didn't have anything
um but after i kind of shared with them
why i was there and like look i just
i need a purpose you know and i feel
like this is it right now
and they let me they let me help and it
completely changed me just spending the
time with those people
but also like i developed this this
patriotism that i didn't really have
while i was there about my country just
because
i was so grateful for what we had you
know finally and right
and also i was like thinking about you
know in history
the united states is as often stood up
for other countries for people that
can't fight for themselves like these
people
and i came back from england after
living there for three years and
racing definitely not like you know
saving lives or anything
and i got an american flag checkered
flag tattoo because i was like i wasn't
like
i don't like other countries but i was
like america's pretty great it is
pretty great it's maybe the maybe the
best probably the best
um but yeah i i just i came back and it
was like
you know we'd already been in
afghanistan now we were going into iraq
and so they were like they needed more
troops and i came back and found out
about this special forces program
where you could come in off the street
um if you passed like
psyche vowel and language i did
barely by the skin of my teeth i lied
they didn't hook me up to an ekg and i
was like i'm totally sane
we believe you trusted you wow you just
you're just very trusting
you look very trusted yeah well you know
that's uh that's on them
so you said that there was a dark time
in your 20s but maybe what i want to go
to before that was like what was your
family like
family was awesome i was really blessed
and i think okay
another thing i probably took for
granted i mean uh
my parents are both super hard working
very you know highly educated my mom got
her phd
uh and is an environmental engineer my
dad is a racehorse veterinarian
they both worked really hard and i
brother and sister
also like kick-ass super successful like
just
not i have nothing to like are you the
first second or third child
i was the first i was the oldest and i
felt a little pressure
i think because my parents were so
successful like not necessarily
financially but just
what their they achieved their dreams
and like crushed it you know what i mean
and they're both super smart my mom like
never got to be
you know i mean that's a difficult
standard it's tough
plus she like worked full-time i mean my
dad works like
you know 70 80 hours a week sometimes
like the raceworks world is
it's full time yeah beyond full time and
but my mom was working a full-time job
too and then
you know raising the three of us kids
and like
making you know making dinner every
night and like
every all the chores they're
hard-working models yeah and like never
why you have such a long list of things
yeah
and they've made it they made it look
easy yeah and so
i yeah i just i ran from that so then
what the hell happened in your early 20s
then why did you feel
like why did you feel um a lack of
purpose
i don't know i i mean i don't i think i
just
that's a great question i really don't
know i don't know where it came from
why i i felt like i didn't matter but i
just remember thinking
you know things like if i wasn't around
the world would keep spinning exactly
the same and
it wouldn't make a difference you know
what i mean and that's like scary stuff
yeah i never thought about hurting
myself or anything like that but i just
i felt like i had no purpose no place
they weren't important i just didn't
belong i felt
more i felt like i belonged more
those six weeks in africa than i ever
had in my life well maybe that emotion
of feeling like you didn't matter was
what
made you able to dive in so deep into
doing something that really mattered
because that's
what you were lacking and that's what
they needed and you're like oh my god
that's what i've been feeling i need a
purpose
these people need my help yeah exactly
i'll sneak in yeah
exactly use my use my charming qualities
to let them
have me stay so i can help exactly no so
that was
and then it was a six-week transfer
transformation yeah totally
i mean i came and i came back and like
felt like i could do anything now
you know what i mean wow still think
that uh
kind of naively but no it's true you
have a little bit of naivety it's not a
bad
my favorite quote is whether you think
you can or you think you can't you're
right yeah exactly
it's true it's very true and uh yeah my
actually my last week there i got
malaria and i was like yeah what's that
like
you want me to go into details i kind of
want you to give an overview of malaria
so that i can know that if i travel to
certain countries like
i'll get the shot you know yeah well i
took the pills i took oh you took the
pills oh skip that then i'll just take
my chances
yeah exactly just risk it you're fine
how long are you sick for if you can't
i was like really bad for like three
days uh three days of like couldn't
really sleep because i was
i mean it was hot you know i'm in like
sub-saharan africa
and i was freezing cold but sweating
bullets at the same time
couldn't keep anything down uh it was
bad
just complete body like the worst flu
you could ever imagine you know
yeah it just sucks and but they put the
family that this fan this really nice
family that had absolutely nothing
put me up in this little mud hut next to
their compound
they put me up in there like took care
of me
looked after me and they had like you
know one of their nephews like literally
caretaker caretaker and he put a little
radio in there
with a bob marley tape was the only one
they had so i listened to it like both
sides like three times and i was done
with bob marley i love bob marley but i
was like that's enough
so i was messing around on the stations
the only one i could pick up was
bbc radio and it was like play-by-play
of the second battle of fallujah which
is this really
you know epic battle in the uh
afghanistan and
and after that i just like it just
dawned on me that's what i'm doing next
i'm going to join the military and i
came back and
you know achieved well
sought had my sights set on being a
green beret wow eventually did achieve
that but yeah it would uh
it took a couple years it's a lot it's a
long training long training cycle for
that but
i'm getting this feeling like you're
like and then i got here and then i just
decided this is what i need to do and
it's making me think of a book i read
called the alchemist
oh yeah have you read the alchemist and
how
and he has an ultimate goal that he's
trying to achieve but he needs to flow
enough to kind of like go through the
steps to
learn the lessons and it might mean you
have to go over here to get over there
but
it's all essentially more of a linear
path than it feels like
right so do you
it's like a super kind of a big question
but is there some ultimate goal
with all this that's that is allowing
you to flow through
all of these different opportunities and
different um
hits that you get of like i need to do
that
because realistically you're actually
trying to get all the way over here to
the specific goal that you have in mind
and so these are just like part of the
process right do you have that
i i i don't i don't i don't know exactly
what the ultimate goal got it so you're
just confused okay
moving on
[Laughter]
i know there's a lot of things i want to
do you know what i mean and i know
time is running out no um
so yeah but i don't i don't know what
the ultimate
the ultimate goal is i just love the i
love that process
that's the i think that's the point
though i love that trying to figure
things out and just that the hustle of
it um
even the rejection in the days you find
out you're getting killed off the show
and stuff like that
yeah it's good stuff it's all you know
the ups and downs if you didn't have the
downs you wouldn't recognize the ups
so you after after you spent
six weeks in darfur and you got malaria
and then came home then you
enlisted into the military yep yep
joined the army with that 18 x-ray
contract which was the one i was talking
about
yeah for the special forces and went off
to basic training
um shortly after and then straight into
airborne school
and then the special forces selection
and then right into the special forces
qualification course which is like
another year and a half
and at some point in time you got a
green beret yeah yeah so after you
finish all that training you get your
green berries
and then then you're off and then they
start deploying you and stuff
amazing um was there any are there any
moments that we're defining in that
experience
yeah after darfur and when you were in
the military yeah
a couple well i'll tell you first about
a person a guy what do you mind and then
i'll tell you
a quick uh story about like my last
deployment actually yeah
so um my first deployment was to iraq
and i just got to this special forces
team and so i'm the fng
everybody knows what that means exactly
and i
go uh you know go overseas and
there's this one specific guy on the
team named brad who's just
i mean he's hilarious but he's just he's
the guy that gives everybody [ __ ]
but also like whenever it's time to get
work done or whenever it's remember
anybody needs a hand
like he's the first one to step up he's
just like that kind of guy you know what
i mean he's always willing and able to
to be there for you and we became really
close he was like a mentor to me even
though we were pretty close in age
um but i just looked up to the guy
because not only that
he had uh he married a single mother who
had a child with uh disabilities
and it was you know a lot of it was
about
the kid too it wasn't just um it wasn't
just i mean obviously he loved his wife
but it was like he knew like
this this this guy needs a father this
is the right thing to do because he'd
been married before and he was like i'm
never getting married again
you know and then he meets lisa and
ethan the kid and he just like fell in
love with both of them and
i just thought that was really admirable
and just you know
something that i probably wouldn't be i
don't know if i'd be willing to do i
wish i would like to say i would but
um you know he just he did that and
and uh he was the one that sort of
encouraged me to go back and play
football
um at a high level at a school like
texas i was thinking of oh maybe i'll go
play like a small school and he was like
no man if you go you're a green beret
you have to go to a big school you'll
figure it out and then
my sophomore year playing in the alamo
bowl
against oregon state and a week before
the game
i talked to brad on the phone um i'd
just gotten this like
disney spirit award at the college
football awards which is really
corny sounding and it is kind of corny
but uh did mickey show up no
mickey did not show up um but then
so i talked to him on the phone and then
the next day i got a call from one of
the other buddies on our team and
and brad passed away the next day oh
jeez and
uh you know and that was really hard his
wife called me shortly after and asked
if i would be a pallbearer in the
funeral
and i was like yeah of course and so i
talked to mac brown the
head coach of the football team and our
games like in six days and he was like
go take care do that and if you make it
back you make it back
and so i did i went there and and uh you
know
was able to carry brad just like i feel
like he carried so many of us like
though
the time we were you know in service and
did he pass in service
yeah he was it was in a training
accident oh my god yeah a training
accident we were on a skydiving team
and uh never go skydiving got it writing
that down now
where it goes was it skydiving
this is tragic man he's just he's why i
say bungie jumping so much better i'm
like you got a chord
like i mean you know you don't want to
be the first of the 500th jump because
that's
you know they get rid of it after 500
jumps but you want to be like you know
200
yeah somewhere in the middle
so i you know we get back and we're like
losing in the fourth quarter
down a couple touchdowns and all of a
sudden like
we just make this epic come back it was
cool because we dedicated the game to
brad and
you know we come back and win that game
and it was it was awesome
um so that was like that was somebody
that i i continue to even now like
really aspire to
not only honor but kind of live like
because he just wasn't
he wasn't afraid to take chances and
you always do the right thing you know
it's always about doing the right thing
met a really amazing human
yeah and then that last at my last
deployment
i was actually playing at texas so i i
joined the national guard
while i was at school in school and so
they would deploy me in the summer time
so i would like do college football take
classes finish my finals early and then
basically like may till august i would
go to afghanistan for like a little over
three months
and it's like my last deployment like a
week or two from coming home
and it was in one of the biggest fire
fights i've ever been in like this epic
you know situation and uh the first
thing running through my mind
was don't get shot anywhere that you
can't
come back and long snap like you know
what i mean like if you get hit i think
don't
get shot is enough of them of a message
it could be kind of cool if you just get
like grazed you know a little like
clipped or something it's like a cool
scar
come on you know and then have like ptsd
about getting shot afterwards
i don't know about that you got ptsd it
doesn't matter it's too late
it's like i have cte yeah exactly and uh
so i you know whatever didn't didn't get
shot luckily
good and uh but after one of the one of
the
afghans we were fighting alongside the
time from the afghan uh
special forces was actually killed and
the
medevac helicopter comes in to to take
his body off and
there was actually three americans and
three afghan soldiers
that were carrying the gurney out to the
bird
um and it was like a really symbolic
moment for me because
in the special forces everything we do
is alongside
uh indigenous forces so we work with
afghans iraqis
you know and they become your brothers
in arms in a while
well and just like i just remember that
that last image
of these guys like carrying his body and
it was it was really cool because it was
just kind of
sort of working together and it like
crushed us as much as it crushed them
you know
losing this guy and uh to just
sort of feel some of the pride in
country that they had developed
over that time even though they live in
such a very difficult place with
so much corruption and you know just
really bad stuff
yeah not great people everywhere and uh
but it was just uh yeah it was really
powerful for me to
to experience that so you you
you grew to understand we're more alike
than different right yeah for sure and
there's camaraderie no matter who you
are where you are
no matter what you look like or where
you live
yeah things about that felt that totally
commonality
bleed the same blood and like we want
the same stuff
at the end of the day you know i've
always i mean obviously i haven't felt
that at the level you have with
the um you know with the
you know risking your life kind of work
you're doing but
um even just in travel that um
people are wonderful yeah like even if
it's supposed to be a scary place or
not nice people i mean i recently was in
france they were nice
yeah i know it was amazing um
so i mean that's like a little
start into something i want to get to
but
so then you decide that you want to play
football
and you want to play in the nfl like
so you make it to the nfl how did that
happen by the way
so i came after i graduated i played in
a senior all-star game
called the medal of honor bowl which was
in charleston and
i didn't know there's gonna be like a
bunch of scouts there i just thought it
was like
you just play in this kind of fun
all-star game but it's sort of a that's
what they use it for
scouts go out they evaluate players and
all that and i had four different teams
say you should
you need to put on like 40 pounds but
you should give it a shot
so i was like all right so i came back
to texas and then moved out here and
started training at jay glazer's gym
unbreakable performance center and i
didn't put on 40 pounds but i put on
about 30
uh over the course of maybe four months
what
i know it wasn't how did you do it i ate
about seven thousand calories a day
got it so that's cardio asking
yes i want to know what not to do okay
so eat less
yes caloric deficit is the only way to
lose weight i know that
it's also very hard um it's also very
hard to eat 7 000 calories a day
you probably feel pretty gross at some
point everyone's like oh you're so lucky
i was like after a week i felt
disgusting oh i bet i bet before seating
whatever
um anyway uh so you make it to the nfl
the seahawks signed me as a free agent
and uh it was
a great experience i played in one game
playing one pre-season game but
you know just to just to have the
opportunity yeah i was up there for
about five months and it was
it was cool yeah that's amazing and of
course like
then you have this
famous slash infamous depending on how
you look at
it situation with colin kaepernick and
how
you know you're standing right next to
him
i'm not even going any further just tell
me the story of yeah
how you were involved with the kneeling
right
so yeah most people by now
know colin kaepernick doesn't know about
the you know his protest during the
national anthem
um his protest is about police brutality
and social injustice
is the best way to put it um and
i guess it was it was august or
september i think august 2016
so we're right right before the election
so it's very
tumultuous time you know it was trump
versus hillary clinton and
right this whole you got to be on one
team or the other and everyone's like
we're already dividing like crazy and
yeah it's it's
it's frustrating especially i think as a
as a war fighter because
you're fighting for everybody over there
moralizing to a society
yeah the more reasons to divide yeah it
is it's it's really frustrating
and so um
[Music]
amidst that you know colin starts
sitting on the bench during the anthem
and it's like huge uproar
uh it blew up even more than i think he
was prepared for and
and expected it to and uh
i wrote this up an open letter that week
uh to
to the army times because i'd been
reached out to by like
fox news cnn msnbc all the big
publications but i knew
if i do something because they knew you
were in the military and because you
were standing next to him
no i hadn't even met him oh i've been in
the military because i played for the
seahawks a year before
oh okay so it was like oh this guy
served our country and also played
football so
he must be the expert on the anthem and
what you should do or whatever you know
but yeah it was really what you think
and i didn't want to really say because
i was like it
first of all it doesn't matter a ton
what i
think um but and also if i if i take an
opinion or a stance it's just going to
cause
more issues it's going to cause more
division but even if i go on a certain
network
because of what that network sort of the
agendas they push sure because they all
do have that yeah
it'll put me in like everyone will
assume i believe all these things
yeah if you're on cnn yeah you're one
way if you're on fox you're another
exactly i'm like i'm not either of those
things like
some things i like on this side some
things i like on that side and that's
who i am
and so i wrote for the army time wrote
it for the army times because not that
many people read the army time
first of all but second of all it's it's
not political at all like it's just
you know it's for the military whatever
and they posted it the next day and a
ton of
sports journalists started sharing it so
it went like crazy viral
and colin ended up reaching out um i was
about to go on the first interview i was
gonna do on tv was for nfl network
because it was also like all right it's
a sports channel it's gonna be less
political and i knew the people there i
felt more comfortable
and so i'm like in the green room and
cohen's publicist called me and said hey
colin's at practice right now
they're playing their last preseason
game tomorrow he's starting
um it's down in san diego is there any
way you'd be willing to go down there
and meet with him before the game he
really wants to talk to you and i was
like
sure so i go down there i'm finding out
as i head down it's like military
appreciation night
like the navy seals are going to do a
flyover and jump into the stadium
and like it's san diego it's a very
military town yeah oh boy
you know this is going to be big so i
went down met him in the lobby of the
team hotel
um and we talked for a couple of hours
and just like you mentioned a second ago
like we had so much more
in common than we had different and like
we
you know disagreed on a few things but i
agreed with a lot of
what he had to say like where it's
coming from as far as like yeah i want
to see things improve i don't want
to see you know any cops doing that i
know
and he acknowledged too like most of
them are really good people
who wouldn't stand for fairness exactly
exactly
and so it was uh it was really just like
that was a conversation and
and and uh and by the end of it he was
just like well
do you think there's another
thing something else i could do or
another way of demonstrating you know
because i'm not going to stand during
the anthem i've already
vowed to not and i don't want to break
that
until i feel like things are moving in
the right direction and changes are
happening
and i was like i mean that's a tough
question because no matter what you do
you're going to get
criticized you know i mean there's just
no there's no perfect protest
or whatever it's supposed to be
uncomfortable right it's messy i mean
it's like
no no there's always pain for growth so
you know the pain is like this is
uncomfortable
for people right exactly um
and i said but i would offer you this i
think it's important right now you're
sitting on the bench sort of isolated
from your team
i think it would look good if you're at
least alongside your teammates whatever
you're doing because
they're they don't all agree with you a
lot of them do but
you're a quarterback you're a leader of
the team um
and i just think you know
being alongside them sort of puts you on
an equal playing field and
whether that's just optically or for
them to like feel like all right it's
not making it about me i'm not making it
about me
i'm doing this with my with my guys and
uh you know and they may not agree but i
think they would respect you more
if if you did that and he said he agreed
to that
and uh and then i said so if you're not
gonna stand like what are you gonna do
because everything's
i don't think sitting on the field is a
good idea and he was like no i don't
think so either
and uh i said what if you you know what
if you took a knee instead i said
as far as i know kneeling has never
really been seen as
like a disrespectful act in the history
of mankind it's like
people look what you did you know i know
look what i started
but like because i don't remember the
sitting part yeah he sat
for two games before that and it was
already national news at that point yeah
so i thought it was a i thought it was a
good adjustment
honestly you know i thought it was like
at least he was willing to listen and
yeah
and and moving that way i think that
that story
definitely got lost and part of that was
maybe on colin for not you know talking
about it
like why he decided to do that instead
but it is what it is
um and it was bizarre because i mean
that night you know the the the
team invited me to come down the field
and you know and stand with them
stand next to him i mean i told him i
was going to stand but i would
you know if he was willing to do that i
would stand next to him
and uh and if you know there's booze
coming from the crowd during the anthem
and the
anthem was being sung by an
african-american navy sailor
it was just interesting man it was it
was crazy i mean
i'm just curious purely curiosity um
as it's not necessarily
something you had a hand in but you did
talk to him for hours
and you know maybe you could maybe you
could tell me how you would do it but
you know maybe the question is is
why was it you know why was it done
at his job like that why it wasn't there
couldn't he go on a little speed
media tour and talk about it like
there's plenty of people i'm sure they
want to sit down with them or what
what write a article for
some you know for for a newspaper or a
magazine that was
in depth about something that he
believed in like
why was it that he felt like i need to
do it here
at the games like this i think because
he
knew he would get the attention you know
there's no
there's with his job what he does
there's no
uh more impactful time to do that
whether you like it or not
like and it started a you know important
conversation even though
the conversation's maybe still going to
be going like this too much
it's something we need to talk about it
needs to be addressed things need to be
fixed
yeah um but also there needs to be in my
opinion a recognition or an
acknowledgement that like
we need good police officers it's
important
and and like something that i'm not
saying colin is doing this specifically
but
a lot of people throughout this time um
have sort of like
uh demonized all cops you know what i
mean
or like sort of put them in a box it's
like demonizing a country or a culture
because
you're another race there's one bad one
like i'm saying a race or something they
believe in something different
so it's like it's hypocritical yeah
otherwise if you're doing that you know
a little general
yeah and we need to get if we need
better cops better training then you
need to
we need to take the system encourage it
or you know like we should want
people to be police officers we
shouldn't be like oh look at another cop
did look another captain all the time
like yes
of course that but you need to also
acknowledge the good stuff and then
and then how difficult that job is yeah
you don't get paid give glory for the
good
yeah you know so you had both sides
coming at you too
right for being disappointed in you yeah
a lot of people in the military too
because i may be damned if you do
damned if you down exactly um but how'd
you deal with that
so entitled to their opinions i mean the
only stuff that really bothered me was
especially i had a couple people that i
served with in the special forces that
you know said some you know call me
disgrace to the green beret so like that
hurt
but otherwise i was like you know there
was there was hardly anybody
i don't even know if i've met anybody
yet that has said it to my face
there's definitely been like people that
have said you know i disagree
respectfully you know i disagree with
your stance and your opinion on it i'm
like that's fine
i don't expect you to you know so i mean
tolerance seems to be something that in
general
there's a lack of in my opinion do you
agree
yeah for sure in our country yeah
there's a lot of from both sides of
these issues you know what i mean like
that's that's something that needs to be
we need to talk about is this this this
idea that
um you know patriotism is a conservative
value and open-mindedness is a liberal
value
right no like there's some of the most
closed-minded people i've ever
met have leaned very very far left and
some of the most unpatriotic people i've
ever met
are very very conservative you know what
i mean and they think they're patriotic
but they're not you know because that's
what our country should be about i mean
we are
super diverse we're actually a very
charitable country
um we have a ton of problems we have a
ton of people
and they're from all over the place and
you know we're just a crazy melting pot
we have to have tolerance or we're gonna
die
you know we're going to implode no doubt
how do we change that
just get rid of social media yeah
[Laughter]
a lot of ways but i mean just getting to
know people
you know communicate conversate listen
like really listen to somebody else try
to put yourself in their shoes
um you know go to those those
neighborhoods and
spend time where other people you know
live and grow up
and and uh i don't know i think
so too many people like live in their
their bubbles whatever their bubble is
and just assume
yeah that the other bubble is bad and
dangerous and
you know ignorant and whatever and uh
it's just stupid
it's wrong yeah like you said we're way
more similar
um what are the ways that you feel like
you've really learned that
um i mean a lot of the travel stuff
really i mean going to the darfur
spending time in the military deploying
i mean when you sit down with somebody
um for instance in
iraq or afghanistan that's you know got
a third grade education
um and you've got your assumptions about
what they
are like because of their religion or
whatever and then you sit down there and
like you talk about stuff
and you laugh about the same stuff right
and you're like oh you
actually just want exactly what i want
right i mean just want to
you just want to belong you know you
want to be part of something you want to
matter
you want to make a difference you want
to if you're a father you want to be a
good
parent uh you know if you're a daughter
you want to
please your mother like whatever it's
the same stuff you know
so it's just talking though and then
once you do that
kind of get past that you don't see it
you know people like that
that are so foreign as like another
species or something you know what i
mean
it's like they're just from a different
place but they're
[Music]
all the way all the ways to divide to me
or
i don't embrace you know like i mean i
think that
you know we it's a lot easier to take
away things that divide us than it is
almost to like learn tolerance even
though the tolerance
really fix everything because if you
just
assume the best in everyone that
everyone's doing their best basically
all the time and you don't know their
situation
and that we don't all have to be exactly
the same then
you walk through life with a lot more
patience i would i need to practice that
in so many different ways especially on
the road i'm sure they're doing their
best they just suck at driving
right and uh that's a daily battle there
but
um it's not fair for them or me because
this definitely doesn't feel fair for me
when they're driving side by side below
the speed
but that's something you're a master
it's a skill like
you know it's not that's not the same
everyone's like
i don't know they're like a baby giraffe
and you're like a
tiger i don't know okay so just driving
is really my only expertise but
um but yeah it's i i feel the same about
travel
i i really feel like i almost i'm i'm
gonna vote for
travel being like the new college i
actually i think that europe does a
fantastic job
of getting out there and traveling and i
mean you know italy shuts down for a
whole month that's a great idea
um but but but in but in europe i think
that they value
sort of international travel and living
with another family
for a year and seeing the world and
taking
you know vacations is something that is
a part of their culture
and i think that you know i
i don't know what it's like to live in
another country maybe they're
everybody's just as sensitive as us but
i feel like
we here can get quite sensitive of other
things going on when it's not in our
comfort zone
we're not familiar like we are scared of
what we don't know
and the best way to
correct that is to get out there
and meet people you don't know see
things you don't know eat food you don't
know
experience a culture you don't know
check out a religion you don't know
i think at the root of it all as you
said the most important thing is we
really all want the same thing
we all want to be you know i don't think
you're ever going to barely meet anyone
that doesn't want to be happy
and have peace and joy in their life
and um and
you know just in general have a calm
easy breezy life but
we make it uh we make things out to be a
bigger deal than they really need to be
and i'm sure
you know i do this about certain things
too but it's that that victim mentality
that division mentality
human nature we all fall backslide into
those things like
even like entitlement you know
i think people assume with your military
they're like oh you must
you know you must still get up at 5am
and work out every day
at six and blah blah blah blah and
i'm like no like i i get back to the
stage from a deployment and i get
comfortable
and then i get lazy and then i [ __ ]
about stuff that i shouldn't [ __ ] about
just like everybody else
like because it's not you know because
it's nice here and it's good and there
is a lot of opportunities and
and anyway but that's like what's a
common thing you constantly have to like
battle that even in
yourself whatever that is tolerance too
um because you're gonna be judgmental
like you can't help that
you know you're gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna have my
moments where i i see something and i
just assume something you know what i
mean
it doesn't mean it's the truth i've
found that the best way to do that
because i've done that in my life too or
thought the worst or um judged something
that you know when once you can identify
when you've done it because that's the
first step is to go i need to correct my
negativity and be more positive and then
you
catch yourself somebody walking by going
like oh look at her and they're like
that was negative
like that's totally uncalled for and
then the first thing is recognizing it
then say something nice right so then
the next thing is go you know what
she's probably doing her best you know
like she's probably have maybe she's
having a tough day i don't know what she
dealt with this morning or what she just
walked away from or
so you correct it with a positive
thought and then over time
you start to automatically go to the
positive thought and it's not possible
to never have a negative thought or a
judgmental thought that's just human
nature that's just being human
but you over time develop a better
thought pattern and reflex and intuition
about people as opposed to
just judging judging right out of the
box so
um but i do believe that i agree with
you that travel is the quickest way
to have a damn good time but also to
really learn that we are all more same
more this
more alike than different exactly um so
you know you've lived this giant life
and you've done amazing things
and you know uh is there any other jobs
that you'd like to get confused in for a
little while in the near future i'm
working here right now i'm getting very
confused in the film and television
industries
i'm kidding you're very inspirational
it's fun no but it i
am i am always a little bit you know
trying to figure that's what that's the
part that i like
as humans we can evolve as people we can
evolve i mean
it's okay to have a new job it's okay to
change
like i think that that's something i had
to face in my own career as far as like
learning the difference between quitting
and letting go at the end i was like
i know that you know me this way as a
race car driver but that doesn't have to
be
me just because that's what you're used
to even if that's just because
that's what i'm used to i can go do
something completely different and still
be me
yeah and so you know learning that
difference between quitting and letting
go
and just readier for a new phase a new
transition and
you're not necessarily a rebirth but a
growth and expansion
right yeah enjoy life shit's short it's
gonna be over soon
it's very short tell me about what's
next yeah but that's so i mean that's a
good segue into
the charity work you know mvp
which stands for merging vets and
players i co-founded it with jay glazer
and we're bringing together combat vets
and former professional athletes
and helping them find purpose and that
newfound identity when the uniform comes
off sure
and one of the things we talk about very
similar to what you were just saying is
this
you know this idea that you're not
the uniform you were war or the job that
you did you know
you're the person who was willing to
sacrifice so much to become elite
outwork everybody you had that grit well
you have
that grit that determination that
relentlessness
to succeed and like you can use that in
and you should use that in any facet of
life and if you
if you can just be willing to try things
and get back out there
there's plenty that you could absolutely
crush you know it could be anything and
and just because you
haven't been doing it your whole life it
doesn't matter um
life is short but at the same time like
yeah i think there's
it's a very american thing to get stuck
in this idea of like
well if i grow up wanting to do this and
i go to college for that
i have to do that forever you know what
i mean right and it's the same with like
athletes veterans all this stuff like
it's not true like you can do 17
different things
and be really good at all of them you
know what i mean and like you have to
obviously
commit and like put the work in but it's
never too late
and when we're seeing so many of our
veterans and our athletes now that like
are starting to to really buy into that
and believe it
and they're getting back out there and
it's not just finding a job it's like
kicking ass at that job and you know
creating
something that's never been done before
and doing it differently because you
have these other experiences you're like
well
i know this industry they've done things
this way for forever
but you know when i was playing ball or
when i was in the military
this is how we sort of crack the code on
stuff you know we we did
kind of reinvent the wheel because it's
a better wheel and
you know why not why can't i do that why
can't i go
you know be whatever i want to be be all
you can be
somebody has to do something for the
first time yeah exactly this will be you
i always say might as well be me right
so
so it's just like it's funny too like
kind of pushing that narrative but also
sitting back and watch watch these guys
that have succeeded at such a high level
be willing to go back and like
you know what i might have to spend a
couple months in the mail room but i'm
gonna be the best freaking milk clerk
they've ever seen and they're gonna pull
me out of there and i'm gonna move here
and then i'm gonna meet you know the
head of this department and he's going
to hear my story and be like oh crap
dude you played in the league for 10
years or you you know you were in the
military like wow
and now you're like this is what you
want to do like it's going to use your
story
like use that is it part of this program
does it include
is there sort of neurological work
no not with us we partner with other
organizations that do that do a lot of
that stuff okay
um but for us it's really just about the
community
on a weekly basis we meet at the gym we
train together
for about an hour and then we hang out
on the wrestling mats afterwards for
another hour
and we just talk about stuff play around
exactly guys hanging out on the mountain
there's girls too
that's a good mix i suppose of course
yeah
but yeah but we just i mean and it's a
very vulnerable time like a lot of the
people they
they talk about stuff they've been
holding in for years again that
vulnerability is where you
create bonds because you've just said to
somebody i trust
that you're not going to judge me i
trust that you're not going to take
advantage
of me now i trust that you're still
going to like me after i say this
i trust that we're still going to be
friends and you know that vulnerability
is a connection point and as you said
at the beginning you know i mean like
that could be a point of weakness when
we think we should do everything
ourselves and so
you know i love that i think that i
think the world needs a whole lot more
tolerance uh and vulnerability and
um we're gonna have a great world then
that's right
we're getting there yeah yeah we're
still pretty new
that's true that's true um only uh
four hang on three point four billion
years how long's this planet been around
something like
that you're probably right i have no
idea human history is a question though
if you lift listen to anyone like graham
hancock or something like that then
you'll be like
how long have humans been here um that's
for another podcast
exactly i guess you got to define human
first
that's for also another podcast exactly
all right well thanks nate thank you
very much annika appreciate it
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button